[Music]
this January I'm doing something that
has never been done I am shooting an
entire film in under two hours and live
streaming it directly in the cinema a
few years back in London I had a most
unhappy experience and I decided that I
would write a comedy about it every
friend I have told me this is a terrible
idea it's going to be a failure which is
how I knew I was on to something the
great Karl Wallenda once said all life
is on the wire and all else is waiting
now I'm not sure how long he said that
before he plunged to his death but I
want you to join me and now it might end
up great it might end up a disaster but
I guarantee you it will be worth
watching
I can't be a leading man forever and I
hope that you will help me make this
career adjustment because I have
children to house and clothe and feed
and besides I have very expensive habits
as a child of the 60s I've always loved
being a part of these happening gather
your friends and come be a part of this
happening with me January 2017
lost in London
[Music]
no one has ever shot a movie and live
broadcasted in the cinemas at the same
time no one's ever been that stupid
until now join me for lost in London a
movie about one of the worst nights of
my life that I thought would make good
promise and if I fail I'm going to jump
off Waterloo Bridge into the pins below
and that should pretty much finish off
my career